say something right power no power every
action is a consequence you have to
really take the consequence regardless
I'm sorry yeah but that's kind of her
point
every action's got a question so what
I'll say is in in that in that scenario
obviously I'm not going to take owners
of the man because I'm I don't I'm not
going to trust a woman straight away
because this is the easiest way to get
trapped and if you've got something
about you and if you're worth anything
then you're not gonna be you're gonna
take some some steps right but once
again what you're doing is you're you're
not you're not placing any blame on the
women you're saying the man is
everything when we don't have the choice
so if if the choice is taken away from
for most men then you can't really put
the blame firmly on on most men so my
thing is this like so you meet women not
as single mothers and for from us men we
look at single mothers and two in two
scenarios baby mothers and single
mothers if you were married and then you
were divorced or your Widow we look at
your single mother
um if you was just had a baby by some
guy situationship whatever it was we
look at you so baby mums and Men we
treat we treat women different so when
we're out now we meet a lot of baby moms
outside and then we look at you like
where's your baby father and a lot of
times you can't get typically higher
than your baby father so what tends to
happen is you guys have gone on bread by
some guy and you might not speak highly
of him you might say all these types of
things but then we think about oh my
gosh that's the guy you chose to give
the highest honor to so when you're
outside now and you're trying to think
you can level up level up your level and
you're saying oh you don't want to
settle what you actually don't want to
do is you don't want to realize what
your actual realistic level is and this
is the problem for a lot of baby mothers
so I kind of just ask them a question
are you would you judge a Woman based on
their previous partners that what you're
saying 100 facts
it's like I have a question for the men
and this is just something I've heard
and tell me if this is true would you if
a girl has an ex that you you think is
like trash like absolutely waste what do
you guys say waste man here that's a
word
is she like tainted yeah 100 100
that goes both ways that goes both ways
so you I'm sorry I'm sorry there's a lot
of men
there's a lot of there's a lot of men
are women lining up to date Drake even
though he had a baby with a cornstarch
but it depends on the person but I feel
like if you look at yourself yeah and
the person you date is a kind of a rep
what you said is is a reflection of you
I do agree so if if someone that you
know has dated someone
um and you don't really like that person
I'm thinking to myself why are you
associating yourself with that person
because that's a reflection on you I
definitely I agree I do agree and that's
why your point about the whole league
thing that we spoke about before I did
semi-agree but there are liars in this
world and there are people that are
manipulators and they can they're really
good yeah
I'm not saying they don't but I'm just
saying that can we not try and ignore it
I'll give you okay okay okay I'll give
you I'll give you a one I'll give you
one no no no no no I'll give you I'll
give you one toxic ax I'll give you one
liar that just Bamboozled you yeah right
I'll give you I'll give you one because
I'm sorry I'm sorry like two three
then then you're toxic 100
girls have one it depends how bad did
you make a kid with that
but but when it becomes a pattern it's
like you didn't get bamboozled every
single time
you have three different
companies
not because I feel like I've been in a
place I feel like before where I wasn't
happy Within Myself and I feel like you
attract a certain kind of person now
when I look back and I now
and in a more comfortable position with
myself with my career the people I'm
around I look at people completely
differently there's different kinds of
people around me so I feel like in the
past I've allowed situate and it's it's
a hard one to take because you're like I
was the person that did that but I've
allowed certain people in my life and I
ignored my gut feeling and that's on me
I can be the victim I could be like oh
they treated me badly yeah but the first
time they treated you badly you went
back and you let them do it again okay
you let them do again you need to
sometimes just be like you know what I'm
a [ __ ] yeah maybe you treated him badly
too yeah like it takes two to tango yeah
exactly that's a conversation like women
always want to talk about oh my lying
cheating ex but why did he cheat most
men aren't looking to cheat what were
you not doing at home I'm serious
I'm
seriously but then also I'll give you
again again I'll give you one one
sometimes there are some friends in my
life but I'm just like time after time
after get again you're in the same
situation with another guy he's just a
different guy same same person doing
treating you the same way it's like
didn't you learn from the last time and
that gets boring and it it's definitely
it's that person you are what you
attract but in life we have to expect
that life is biggest lesson is
experience so you have to go through
yeah I disagree you can't go through the
same situation multiple times that's
what I'm saying because that kind of
because if you let's say because you're
saying you have to if every person
you've dated let's say has a different
toxic trait then it's different but most
of the time when I look at my um the
reason why it wasn't working out before
I didn't have good boundaries for myself
yeah so I I allow people to do things
now that I've worked on that and I'm
actively working on that that won't
happen to me again but I have to take
responsibility in my past to be like you
know what I allowed that to happen I
allowed them to do that to me I went
back that's on me and I feel like a lot
of people nowadays because of this
cancer culture and everything they're
always like it's other people other
people yeah at the end of the day you
came on this Earth and you need to take
this yeah you need to make choices and
take responsibilities
like then you had 10 choices that you
didn't make that went into that one
child you had the plan B you had birth
control you had you had no no so I'm
saying it wasn't just one bad decision
it was like 10. that got you you could
only get pregnant like three days a
month and then back to the cheating
thing like it goes It goes back to
there's two different types of reasons
that girls keep getting cheated on you
either pick a top 20 Guy where that
girls are thrown at him all the time and
that's your choice like it kind of goes
back to I always say if you date an NBA
player or you know even I'll even give
you a basketball player out here if you
date one of them and you get you get
cheated on I don't really feel bad for
you you pick that's what you picked or
number two you're not doing something at
home it's hard for men to get sex so
like if you're not sleeping with your
man I don't feel bad if you get cheated
up well you know you know what it sounds
like to us like this just sounds like to
us like you spent your 20s chasing bad
boys getting one free chat in Tyrone and
then in your third or whenever it is you
decide that actually the results wasn't
as good you come out with a kid yeah you
come up more damage now and now you
start looking at guys you didn't look so
for us now it doesn't it's gonna be so
it doesn't sound like you know what does
it sound like we're getting we're
getting someone that's got more trauma
they might have children
um and then now what do I actually get
so so what what good is it to men I know
but no I was just saying based on what
you said before about sometimes if a
woman's got a toxic ex orb someone who's
just trash basically you would look at
them and say you just basically not
you're not interested in them that'll be
a deal breaker for you so I was just
saying
for some people in some cases they have
they they go they make that one mistake
and you're saying they had 10 choices
but I go back to that point of can we
not can we can we not forget there are
people that really do
they're good at manipulating and acting
like they are one person up until whilst
you're pregnant like the lady we had on
the platform before no no no no no no no
no no no no no she said there were red
flags yeah and then maybe but then you
have to take into account her age she
also said she was 21. so also that she
recognizes
yeah you're 21. so I don't really think
that's young that's just my opinion okay
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
so so on top of that she had the choice
to have a kid before you got married or
after you got married and she could have
said she could have said I'm gonna have
an IUD until I have a ring she could
have did that she didn't make that
choice she could have made the choice to
track her cycle she could have made the
choice to go on birth control she could
have made the choice to get an abortion
she could have made the choice to pick a
guy that didn't have all these red flags
but it's like 10 choices that go into
the one choice I'm not saying she's a
bad person I'm not like she's beautiful
I'm sure she'll like find someone else
but it's gonna be a lot harder now and I
understand why men wouldn't want to deal
with that have you ever been a victim of
fraud like online frauds
um you know what I think that my venmo
hacked once
I've had this multiple yeah and you know
what you know and I would say when I got
my venmo hacked it was my own damn phone
my
Uncle choices and if someone said then
you are you're an idiot for doing that
yeah and I look at you right now yeah I
would say
I would say hey they probably could
steal from wait actually
no but you can I let me quickly just say
something here because I feel like I'm
probably the youngest on this panel
um I'm 21 in it and I understand my
value enough to understand that my
partner reflects my value on vice versa
so I would never really commit to
anybody that I
I know is
not not gonna match that to an extent
right also I think as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible